DISTRICT THROUGH WEDNESDAY OF
NEXT WEEK.
BRET.
>> Bret: CASEY STEGALL LIVE IN
SANTA FE.
THANK YOU.
PRESIDENT WILL BE ON LONG ISLAND
MARGIE DOC ABOUT GANGS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS COME UNDER
FIRE FOR REFERRING TO MEMBERS OF
THE NOTORIOUS MS-13 GANG AS
ANIMALS, AND YOU MAY REMEMBER
SOME IN THE MEDIA AT LEFT OUT
THE MS-13       MS-13 REFERENCIG
THE MS-13       MS-13 REFERENCIT
THE MS-13       MS-13 REFERENCIE
ORIGINAL COVERAGE.
CORRESPONDENT BRYAN LLENAS TELLS
US YOU WILL LIKELY HEAR THAT
DESCRIPTION AGAIN.
>> OVER THE LAST YEAR, I.C.E.
RAIDS TARGETING MS-13 GANG
MEMBERS HAVE INCREASED.
IN 2017, I.C.E. ARRESTED GANG
MEMBERS NATIONWIDE, THE HIGHEST
TOTAL SCENE IN NINE YEARS.
IT IS ALL PART OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S INITIATIVE TO
DEFEAT THE BROODY        BRUTALL
DEFEAT THE BROODY        BRUTALY
DEFEAT THE BROODY        BRUTALV
DEFEAT THE BROODY        BRUTALO
DEFEAT THE BROODY        BRUTALE
DEFEAT THE BROODY        BRUTALT
DEFEAT THE BROODY        BRUTALG
DEFEAT THE BROODY        BRUTALN
FROM EL SALVADOR.
ESTIMATING MS-13 HAS 10,000
MEMBERS IN THE U.S.
LOS ANGELES TO VIRGINIA TO
LONG ISLAND.
ON WEDNESDAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL HOST AN MS-13 ROUNDTABLE ON
LONG ISLAND TO DISCUSS PROGRESS
MADE AND WHAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
>> WHEN THE MS-13 COMES IN, WHEN
THE OTHER GANG MEMBERS COME INTO
OUR COUNTRY, I REFERRED TO THEM
AS ANIMALS.
GUESS WHAT.
I ALWAYS WILL.
>> IT IS TRUMP'S INSISTENCE ON
REFERRING TO MS-13 GANG MEMBERS
AS ANIMALS THAT HAS OUTRAGED
CRITICS WHO BELIEVE HE WAS
CALLING ALL IMMIGRANTS ANIMALS.
REPUBLICAN PETE KING OF
LONG ISLAND DEFENDS TRUMP.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS ENTIRELY ON
TARGET.
THE ONLY CRITICISM I WOULD MAKE
IS THAT HE IS BEING UNFAIR TO
ANIMALS.
ANIMALS DON'T KILL AND TORTURE
THEIR OWN.
>> ON WEDNESDAY THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS SHERIFF DOESN'T AGREE WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S RHETORIC BUT HE
SAYS THE PRESIDENT SUPPORT IS
MAKING A DIFFERENCE AND THEY
NEED MORE OF IT.
>> IF I CAN GET FUNDING FOR MY
PROGRAM SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO GO
INTO MIDDLE SCHOOLS WHERE WE ARE
THWARTING GANG RECRUITMENT.
>> FIGHTING MS-13 POSES BIG
RISKS.
POLICE ARE ON HIGH ALERT AFTER
THE GAME CALLED ON ITS MEMBERS
TO KILL AN OFFICER BECAUSE